i'm gonna delve into the latest rumors  of how apple is finishing out the  releases of their final lcd and mini led  ipad pro models while setting in stone  their master plan for switching to oled  displays across their entire ipad lineup  my prediction is that in the fall of  2023 apple's gonna release a new ipad  air with an ole display however it will  not be better than the mini led ipad pro  models in the spring of 2024 apple to  release a new 12.9 inch ipad pro model  with an even better oled panel they'll  essentially have two of the same display  panel stacked on top of each other to  literally double the brightness and then  sometime in 2025 the 11 inch ipad pro  model to get updated with that same new  oled display and then the ipad mini will  adopt the lower end oled display also  probably in 2025 in 2026 the budget ipad  will get the oled display